the jurogan experience you know what's
good about that too if you're ever in a
real altercation you're used to people
resisting a hundred percent
um because like if you're like a karate
guy and you used to like point touching
each other did you see that karate i was
about
how do you feel he loses he how do you
feel pride you get knocked out yeah in
the gold medal match up
and you win the gold and the other guy's
disqualified he's disqualified for
hitting you too hard and here's the
thing was [ __ ] up is like it's not
like he was standing there he kind of
leaned in to the kick like he bent over
and the dude caught him so it's kind of
on you a little bit too
yeah let's watch it let's watch it
because it's so dumb and uh i didn't a
friend of mine sent that to me and
here it is look at this look he
bends over yeah
and to be honest it's a counter the guy
throws a straight left he counters with
the kick catches him hit him then he's
just fake sleeping oh he's getting out
of here dude he's sleeping
oh he thought he won two poor guy well
he should have won in a real world
scenario and any other rational sport
that's a combat sport he won that's the
problem with like olympic combat sports
is they try to take the violence out of
it but what doesn't make any sense is
you could win by knockout in tae kwon do
oh i didn't know that that's in the same
thing uh it's in the olympics too like
why
why specifically why what is the
difference why do you have karate and
tae kwon do yeah the only difference is
you're you're allowed to punch in the
face in this and is it point karate is
that what it is yeah i heard it was kuma
i don't know i don't know though
is the japanese word for sparring okay
so yeah that doesn't make sense i just
heard someone saying it while i was
watching i think that's the word for
sparring i think that's what it means i
mean they got all the different types of
swimming so i guess you're going to have
all the different types of martial arts
you know
you got to do things to stack the metals
right like if you're good at some [ __ ]
like america we're good at running so
we're just gonna okay 400 kilogram
kumite final
yeah
so dumb yeah
ridiculous
oh they also they have uh individual
demonstrations like kata and then they
have one on one kuma that's the most
ridiculous one i'm not trying to shoot
on this guy he probably kicked my ass
but the guy won a gold medal for dancing
getting ko oh yeah for the kata for the
kata yeah but it was just choreography
well you could win for gymnastics
yeah but gymnastics isn't a fight
like i see martial arts as
this is fighting right like in order to
be good at it you have to be able to do
that [ __ ] on someone the
kata thing is like you would have to
learn those to get your belts like you'd
avocado for
one specific one you had for blue belt a
specific one you had for green belts and
i remember when i did taekwondo as a kid
we had that yeah yeah and all that yeah
i hated those what the taekwondo this
stuff all right yeah
the forms
poomsae
american gold doubloons
he won the first evil karate medal
in men's kata
the first ever for america or the first
ever time they handed it out
uh
oh my gosh that's so ridiculous
the intensity serious
yeah the thing is like it's not a bad
thing to practice movement like it's
almost like kind of like a form of yoga
in a way like you're practicing moving
your body and if you get really good at
doing those kadas it'll probably enhance
your ability to move which will enhance
your ability to spar but you're not
giving anybody a medal for shadow boxing
good [ __ ] point that'd be ridiculous
good [ __ ] imagination
i'm a boxing gold medalist a gold medal
for shadow boxing
or hitting the cobra bag you know that's
a bag worth gold
backward gold medal be better than this
because we can see something land
kicks yeah like you know this poor guy
just got back to america with his gold
medal we're just trying this is the guy
who wants he was they were going against
each other though oh and this guy how do
you oh they judge it they judge the
karate come on come on the uh the kata
rather yeah we used to have those in
tournaments in taekwondo tournaments
they would have the the kata version or
the i forget what they call it i think
it's called poomsae they call it korean
and then they would have the sparring
part now you'd have to wait around while
these
dummies threw [ __ ] air kicks
yeah yeah watch the entire episode for
free only on spotify